we're getting brand new details on the
Biden bribery scheme House Republicans
doing the FBI document alleging that
then Vice President Biden was paid five
million dollars by an executive with
Ukrainian natural gas firm marisma which
you may remember is the same company
that his son Hunter Biden had a board
seat on the president brushing It Off by
using his signature catchphrase
Nancy Mason through standing evidence in
the FBI file that he sold out the
country do you have a response to
Congressional Republicans where's the
money I'm joking Mr President
[Music]
so Jesse the money is in all those shell
companies that Hunter Biden allegedly
set up to basically money launder to
many different Biden family members
he's like he's like yeah where where is
it like we know we haven't found it yet
right God this guy's cocky so you have
10 million going to Joe and Hunter
from barisma
this allegation popped in 2017. that
means the FBI had this allegation
during the impeachment over Ukraine
Donald Trump fingered the Biden family
for this exact scheme and got impeached
for it and the FBI knew it had legs the
entire time and then the election they
spiked a laptop till and then they
rented his house but the everything's
fair at the Department of Justice how
about this the barisma guy is paying Joe
Biden five million dollars to what to
fire the prosecutor which Joe Biden
admitted on tape be fired
there you go that's exactly what this
impeachment hoax was all about and then
the guy says but we're going to disguise
it through shell companies so the money
doesn't actually get seen going to Joe's
bank account wait a second it's exactly
how the Chinese set up the money launder
it through shell companies but it
doesn't hit Joe's bank account it only
hits uh nine other members of the Biden
family's bank account like his
granddaughter and his brother and his
corrupt son so it doesn't matter if you
don't pay Joe if you pay the whole
family and then the whole family pays
for houses and cars and tuition that's a
bribe and that's an impeachable offense
and the fact that you now have this
allegation and Tony bobolinski and the
laptop and the coma records from One
Bank remember there's ten Banks left who
knows what they're going to find in
those 10 other Banks this thing's just
getting started and that's why the
Republicans happen have to open up an
impeachment inquiry to get to the bottom
of this corruption so Greg when when Joe
Biden continues to deny all of this even
though he was Hunter Biden's business
partner isn't he just insulting the
intelligence of everybody who can look
at this and go it's obvious that he was
benefiting from Hunter Biden's business
deals and it hurts Hunter's feeling
things because he worked really hard on
this stuff you know the people in the
media they drooled over what they could
get on the Trump family business but at
least those businesses were real even
Trump University sold the name it was a
licensing deal but they produced a
profits in exchange for services Trump
hotels whatever real estate the only
product the Biden family produces are
empty crack files and outbreaks of
chlamydia I mean they had to launder
that money God knows where Hunter was
inserting those bills but it's not so
much that the Biden family is a criminal
family because they are it's that the
media is so lethargic about this
corruption you know the you know nothing
Trump there's nothing that comes close
to this that the Trump family did you
wonder where Woodward and Bernstein are
but I'll have to say turnabout is fair
play the problem with weaponizing things
that have to be fair to all people your
turn in the barrel will come I'm not
that interested in locking up Hunter or
Joe Biden but the other side would lock
up every one of us if they could so let
she's not a real doctor how long has she
been practicing on patience telling them
that she's an actual doctor
um Jessica you know the media has tried
to spin this as if Republicans are kind
of making up a scandal about the Biden
family Democrats have also said that but
the Obama White House and state
department had serious concerns about
purisma corruption in fact the Press
office was asked about this in Hunter
Biden's dealings at the time in his
connection to this firm and yet Joe
Biden continues to say he had nothing to
do with it I mean
the evidence shows to the contrary at a
very basic level
so I agree with Elizabeth Warren who was
the first person who was running for
president in 2020 Democrat to come out
and say that that Arrangement having
your son working for a company like that
would not be acceptable and that the
ethics rules need to be revised and I
think that we can all agree that that
should be the case it shouldn't be
allowed and Joe should say that that
this isn't something that he would do
again
but
we have yesterday Chad pergram our own
our very that's what we're supposed to
say our very own chat program which by
saying our very own makes him the best
which he is yes saying that a source
familiar with the document told Fox News
to be clear the document does not say
Joe Biden received any payments now I
know what you're going to say this is
not how the mob works Chad I'm sorry
your tenure has been great but Greg has
disowned you I understand when you're a
mafia family it's never written down
right because you have a really rich
granddaughter off of it but Republicans
like Comer Nancy Mays Chuck Grassley
continue to go on TV and say that they
have a thing they have evidence of a
thing that they don't have on the Victor
Shogun the family was brought no Joe
Biden
no that's well you're not going to be
able to put okay your husband you're
innocent I'll just bribe your husband
and you do what I want you to do so
that's how it works Jessica what's great
about making Easter cute as arguments is
that you can never be wrong but you also
can never be right so we'll just keep
going I just was right you know not
according to this isn't this what this
has always been about about Joe Biden's
role in this like as a former vice
president the current president are you
referring to the big guy yeah the big
guy he's always been about that it's
always been about Joe Biden you have to
wonder how a guy who's been in
Washington for 47 years a half a century
with nothing to speak of has attained
the highest levels of power in the
United States in some of the shadiest
business dealings that we have ever seen
in the history of this country in the
most weaponized Justice apartment and
law enforcement agencies and it's
intelligence agencies I mean I I don't
even need to go much past that but what
I will tell you is that the 1023 that
came out saying Joe Biden took was given
five is someone's given five in Ukraine
you know that country where we keep
giving billions and and
um
the Raskin comes out a Democrat
Congressman as if he knows everything
right he comes out and he says it was
likely to be disinformation I mean don't
they have another Playbook it sounds
like everything that the Democrats don't
like is this information but Bill Barr
the Attorney General of the United
States comes out and he says uh the
information was checked out it was
determined that it's not likely that it
was disinformation the exact opposite
and that it was to be continued in terms
of the investigation and Bill Barr
doesn't understand why they haven't
concluded that investigation I will add
my humble opinion that is that the very
existence of any information relating to
the bidens will be covered up he is
corrupt and the amazing part of it is in
this 1023 that came in in June of 2020
before the laptop before bobolinsky
in that 1023 the FBI credible Source
says they talk about the big guy so we
hear from the big guy from the same
credible Source that's corroborated in
the laptop corroborated by Bob olinsky
corroborated Now by Comer and his
information and the shell companies and
the llc's and the 10 million 20 million
Etc
yep and Biden denies it all hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else